[Music]
i came across this video from
joe rogan where he was showing his
absolute bedazzlement
and surprise at h.g wells and some of
the predictions that hg wells made so
let's take a look at the clip
and come back and make a comment on this
born 150 years ago
phone's email and television what is
that real
in this alternate reality people
communicate exclusively with wireless
systems that employ
a kind of co-mingling of voicemail and
email-like properties
holy people do not talk together on the
telephone he writes
a message is sent to the station
of the district in which the recipient
is known to be
and there it waits until he chooses to
tap his accumulated
messages whoa then he talks back to the
senders and dispatches any other
messages he wishes the transmission is
wireless
how how what
i'd like to know if he did drugs back
then which citizens used
wondrous forms of technology like the
audiobook
airplane and television what in the [__]
man as you guys saw there
i mean joe rogan was an absolute shock
about this man who was talking about
these new technologies that were going
to
to to to happen in the future now bear
in mind
h.g wells didn't exist 3 400 years ago
500 years ago 600 years ago
h.g wells died in 1946
and he saw the invention of the
aeroplane and the television and the
all of those things so all of those
predictions were very
like it didn't take too much of a
speculation
now listen to this if you find those
predictions
from a man who died practically
yesterday in historical terms and
obviously i mean this exaggeratedly
because i'm going to be oh this person
doesn't know what yesterday
people please understand the language
then how would you react to a man a
thousand
four hundred years ago named muhammad
who is the prophet muhammad who
in fact predicted where islam would
spread exactly
that the earth has been projected from
me and
that i saw its east and left
oh sorry east and west sides and that my
nation i e the nation of muslims
will inhabit those areas what was
projected on there for me
and he goes more specific telling us
where islam was spread
and then authentic narrations telling us
where islam would go
even ahead you're going to go into india
and obviously we have a very healthy
population of india indian muslims
ascend which actually is part of
pakistan now
egypt misra
he said allahummabad
yemen so in other words the muslims
would inhabit yemen
which is the levant region the levant
and all of these different places and
there's more i'm just giving you a
little bit of a taster
you may say well this is all kind of
ancient history anyways
but the prophet muhammed predicted
that there will be barefooted arabs
barefooted arabs competing for the
highest buildings
compare that with the hg wells things
that you are reading with all due
respect
now the tallest building in the world is
burj khalifa
in the uae compare that with the hg
wells things that you were
where you were citing
that the prophet muhammed told us that
interest would be
everywhere that we wouldn't be able to
avoid its dust
now we have capitalistic systems of
economy
supply side economics which means that
virtually
governments have to set interest rates
the prophet told us
the prophet told us that there would be
a spread of sexually transmitted
diseases
as a result of lewd practices people
would do and such
sexually transmitted diseases would not
have appeared in the past in other words
there would be new sexually transmitted
diseases
there is even a hadith in sahih muslim
where the prophet said
there will come a time where you will be
gliding on the earth
with suraj which basically is
like an old roman ship and these old
roman ship had wheels
by the way and it's on the earth that
you'd be gliding
reclining on leather chairs listen to
what it's saying
reclining on leather chairs you'll be
gliding
on the earth reclining on leather chairs
such that when you open the door
women will come out muslim women to the
mosques that's how they'll be going to
mosques and they'll have certain
hairstyles which is like the
hump of a camel very specific
and many modern day scholars say this is
talking about obviously cars
extremely specific stuff now if you're
very
amazed about h.g wells
h.g wells who died in 1945
talking about certain technologies
talking about certain technologies and
i've just given you by the way a taster
there's more than this count
six things before the day of judgment
the prophet said this
my death from
after that the conquest of jerusalem
the jerusalem was the crown jewel of the
roman empire and the prophet muhammed
predicted
that it would be conquered by the
muslims and it was by um
and his time which was only some five
years some some five years after the
death of the prophet muhammad maybe a
little bit more
how can he know all of these things
how can you successfully predict the
future
so precisely so sophisticatedly
and so meticulously in this way
now if you are impressed with h.g wells
and you think there's a lot bit of
question mark there
how did he know this information
although he died
in the mid 40s my question to you joe
rogan
my question to you is what do you make
of all of those predictions
and quite frankly even if you try and
shrug it off
we don't need your validation the answer
is already clear
was